Україна залишається в десятці
найменш мирних країн світу.
Такі результати дослідження британського Інституту
економіки та миру. Сусідами України у рейтингу
Глобального індексу миру стали Центральноафриканська республіка,
Судан і Лівія.
Втім, на відміну від дві тисячі п’ятнадцятого року,
орік позиція України дещо покращилась.
Якщо говорити про Україну,
то ситуація покращилась щодо рівня тероризму, кількості  ув’язнених
та зовнішніх конфліктів.
Позитивно вплинули
на індекс миру, зокрема, зменшення кількості сутичок і демонстрацій  із застосуванням сили,
а також  збільшення Україною фінансування
миротворчих місій ООН.  А от серед мінусів –
мілітаризація суспільства, особливо поблизу зони бойових дій,
політизація військових; також
зросла кількість вбивств ватажків сепаратистів
на окупованій території.
Щоб значно поліпшити позицію України у рейтингу,
потрібне мирне врегулювання
конфлікту на Сході країни, говорять автори дослідження.
Торік усі держави світу вклали у війну
понад трильйон доларів,
а на встановлення миру - менше одного відсотка
від цієї суми - десять мільярдів доларів,
йдеться у дослідженні. Втім є позитивні тенденції.
Рівень миру в світі зріс
на нуль цілих двадцять вісім сотих відсотка.
93 країни світу покращили індекс миру,
а 68 - погіршили. Вперше з 2011 року
ми спостерігаємо збільшення рівня миру у світі.
Вже вкотре
найбільш мирною країною світу залишається Ісландія.
Наступні у рейтингу - Нова Зеландія та Португалія.